(suspenseful music)
- Today, we're about to
get our noses pierced.
- I'm fucking psyched.
I can't wait.
I've wanted my nose pierced
since I was 14 years old.
- I've always seen piercings
as another form of self expression.
- All in all I think piercings
are absolutely beautiful.
- I told my mom about
my piercing last night
and she was just like, silent.
- Fucking scared, I hate needles,
so we better go do this
before I change my mind.
(lighthearted music)
- I'm Brian Keith Thompson,
we're at Body Electric Tattoo
and, actually, today is
my 10 year anniversary.
What we're gonna do first
is clean your nostril,
mark your nostril, pierce your nostril.
Not gonna surprise you,
so don't be nervous.
We're gonna do this by the numbers, relax.
Don't let your mind win, just relax.
Okay, give me a big, giant deep breath,
all the way in, all the way out.
(exhales)
Deep breath all the way in.
(dramatic music)
- I love it!
Wow, this is crazy.
- Oh my God.
- It look so good!
- Oh, my God!
(laughs)
- Oh, yeah.
- It's perfect.
- That looks dope.
- I love it so much
and it was so painless.
- I'm really happy with it,
I think its really cute.
- Soon as it finished, I
looked at myself in the mirror
and I was like, oh, looks like
I've always had a nose ring.
- If you're thinking
about getting a piercing
and it actually means something to you
then you should definitely go for it.
(dramatic music)